We are following several breaking news  stories at 11 o'clock that includes  three deadly accidents on Valley roads  that have claimed the lives of four  people one of them happening near the  Fremont Street Experience Metropolis say  a couple was hit and killed while in a  crosswalk just after 7 30 tonight  Witnesses told police that a red SUV was  the one that hit both victims and  officers were able to locate that driver  a short time later  we had witnesses that were able to  identify the vehicle we had video that  was able to identify the vehicle we had  officers respond to the registered owner  the address of the registered owner of  the vehicle they have contacted that  driver and that driver is now in custody  and officers do believe the driver was  impaired